-We love you! Come on.
-No, no!
-Let's get into everything
that you've been doing.
-No.
-First of all, you're hosting
"Saturday Night" --
-No!
-You!
No, you!
-No, you.
-It is all you right now.
-What?
-"Saturday Night Live."
You're hosting it this weekend
with Sam Smith.
Unbelievable.
-I know.
-This is a giant deal.
-Are you excited?
-I'm scared.
Hold me.
-No. No, you're not scared.
-Hold me!
-You actually --
You used to intern there.
-I did.
I was an intern
in the design department
for the four set designers,
who I know you're aware of.
-I do love the designers.
-Leo.
-Yeah, Leo Yoshimora, yeah.
-Eugene.
-Eugene, of course.
-And Keith.
-And Keith Raywood.
I love them all, they're great.
-Uh-huh.
They loved me.
They loved me because, um,
I did not care about
set design at all.
[ Laughter ]
And they wanted an intern
that had no interest
in learning what they did,
because they were
moody bastards.
[ Laughter ]
And you know that's true.
-They are.
-I mean, I love them, but --
They are moody.
-They are.
In fact, their office
was labelled "The Moody Room."
-It was, actually.
Yeah, yeah.
They know what they're doing.
-They were so grumpy.
-Well, you weren't there when
I was there, though, right?
-I was there 2004, 2005.
-Oh, that's when I left.
Yeah.
-Um, yeah, I know.
I replaced you.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's right.
Congratulations.
They picked perfectly.
-They had to get
the energy shift.
-Who was on the cast?
Did you get to talk
to the cast at all?
-I didn't really talk
to the cast 'cause I was --
I was -- you know,
I was an intern.
I was, like, kind of stalking,
lurking in the shadows.
-But you studied
the whole thing.
You go, "Oh, this is great."
-I studied like a sponge.
I was just, like, creepy.
Like, I was a creepy stalker.
Like, now I'm gonna host it,
so my master plan worked.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
But you actually got to audition
also for "Saturday Night Live."
-I did.
I -- I didn't do, like --
I didn't make it to the bit --
like, to the Lorne audition,
you know,
the famous final audition,
but I did, like, a preliminary
first-round showcase at ECB.
-Did you do characters?
Did you do, like,
original characters?
-I did.
I did some characters.
-Do you remember any of them?
-I remember one character I did
was, like, a -- kind of like
a Puerto Rican, like,
news reporter that was always
trying to, like,
make all of
the news stories sexy,
even if they were, like,
horrific news stories.
[ Laughter ]
And I was just trying to, like,
sex up the news or something.
I don't remember.
And then the other one was,
I was, like,
a pill-popping housewife
that had my own talk show,
called "Celebri-tails,"
where I would just
name celebrities
and name what kind of tail
they would have if they were --
if they had a tail.
[ Laughter ]
Like, I would say, like,
"Lindsay Lohan would have, like,
a bushy squirrel's tail."
[ Laughter ]
Or, like, "Bill Clinton would
have, like, a polar bear's nub."
[ Laughter ]
Or, like, Oprah Winfrey would --
-Oh, my gosh.
-Just stuff like that.
Anyway, I didn't
get on the show, so...
-No. But here you are.
-I know.
-I mean, "Saturday Night Live."
Hosting "Saturday --"
I haven't seen you since
you were on for "White Lotus."
-Yeah.
-You were unbelievable.
-Thank you.
-It was amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You were fantastic.
I couldn't take
my eyes off of you.
You nailed it.
-Yeah.
-You crushed it.
My wife was like, "Oh, my gosh.
Aubrey Plaza's un--"
We worshipped you in our house.
-Thank you.
-We were just like,
"What is going down?"
You had it.
I'm like, "Oh, my gosh.
You got every nomination."
The show got a Golden Globe.
-I know.
-The cast got nominated
for a SAG award.
-I know. Jennifer Coolidge,
racking it up.
-Jennifer Coolidge won.
I mean, the whole cast.
And you, buddy.
You were the secret sauce.
You're the glue.
-Oh, I was barely there.
I was barely there.
-No, my gosh.
It was just unbelievable.
-I was just trying
to save my marriage.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Exactly right, exactly.
So you had "White Lotus"
come out,
and it couldn't
have been better.
Man, again, thanks,
congrats on that.
And thanks for being here.
-Yeah.
-Then you also had
"Emily the Criminal"...
-Yes.
-...which is fantastic.
This is another one
that's getting nominated.
Awards everywhere.
In fact, look at this --
Barack Obama's
favorite movie's of 2022.
-I know. We got Obama!
-Look at this --
"Emily the Criminal."
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-Come on!
-I know.
-How great is this?
-I don't know.
-It's so exciting.
-I wonder if Joe Biden
watched it.
-Yes, he probably saw it, too.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, Joe.
-Yeah, come on, Joe.
Come on, dude. Just say
you liked "Emily the Criminal."
-I know.
-The reviews on this
are fantastic.
94% on Rotten Tomatoes.
You actually produced it,
as well, right?
-I did, yes.
I had my hands all over it.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-Can we set up the --
he idea of
"Emily the Criminal"
for everybody?
-Yeah. So it's a --
it's about a woman named Emily,
who I play,
who is from New Jersey.
She's in Los Angeles
trying to make it
after having a criminal record.
She has, like, a misdemeanor
felony charge from her past.
And she's kind of saddled
with student debt
and trying to just navigate this
broken system that we're in.
And she basically
gets tipped off
to this kind of
credit-card-scam operation.
-Yeah.
What is it called? Dummy?
-Dummy Shopper.
-And she decides to try it out,
and it turns out
she's really good at it.
So, she just --
-Almost too good.
So, she keeps kind of
going down this rabbit hole
of kind of crime.
And then she just becomes, like,
a full-blown criminal.
-Yeah.
-Um, so it's --
Yeah, it's a thriller.
-It's a thriller.
It's fantastic.
You're great in it.
-Thank you.
-I also wanted to mention, too,
that I didn't even realize --
'cause the movie's over,
and I was reading reviews
about it.
There's no gun violence in this.
-There's no guns.
Yeah, there are no guns
in the movie.
I think that's a really cool,
kind of weird thing
about the film, because most
thrillers introduce guns,
like, immediately.
-I didn't even think about it.
-I know.
I don't think it's like --
it's an unconscious thing,
I think, for the audience
to watch that movie
and not even realize,
like, "Oh, there's no guns."
But I think it actually makes it
more, kind of, anxiety-inducing,
because you're like,
"How is she gonna
take these guys down
without, like,
a weapon like that?"
But, um,
I was kind of proud of that.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I don't think
you need guns -- we don't need
guns in every movie.
-You did it.
Yeah, exactly.
Come on. Why not?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Put a little extra work
in there.
Make it -- come on, make it --
it's great.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Aubrey Plaza
in "Emily the Criminal."
Take a look at this.
-Can you tell us what happened
with the assault?
-No.
-[ Scoffs, chuckles ]
No?
-No, why would you trick
somebody like that?
-I -- oh, I did not trick you.
-Yeah, you did.
-[ Scoffs ]
What I did is very common.
That's a very common technique.
-Oh, is that right?
So you do that all the time?
-If people chose to be honest,
then I wouldn't have to do that
all the time.
-Well, you know what?
[Bleep] this.
I don't even want to work here.
-Emily, I'm sorry you're upset.
-No, you're not.
-Calm down, please.
-I am calm. And you ask me
why I want this job?
'Cause I've got $70,000
of student debt.
There's your [bleep]
answer right there.
-All right, yeah,
you need to leave.
-Actually, you know what?
Give me this.
-I -- okay, fine, thank you.
-Yeah, thank you, too.
Excuse me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aubrey Plaza, everybody!
"Emily the Criminal"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We're playing a fun new game
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.